[__] out here maybe we were like we'll
never get a famous person to do this so
we shouldn't even ask someone and then
one day Jonah was like I bet Channing
Tatum would do it you know he's gonna
love this what do you mean and I emailed
him saying like I'm not going to
sugarcoat this it is not a forgiving
roll Channing introduce yourself
hey what's up man you will have to be on
your hands and knees for two days
straight basically I probably had too
much to drink the night that that I got
this email at like three in the morning
I think they were already filming and
you will play Danny McBride's like
sexual [__] play thing and he's like hey
I hope this isn't insulting but I had we
had this idea on the set for a cameo and
it involves you Danny McBride and a
Mexican wrestling Max mask and a leash
and within 30 seconds I got an email
back he was just like yes I'm in wait
tell me where and when and I'll do it I
was just like must have been on Ambien
and drunk and I was just like yeah of
course yeah I'll do it no problem and
they ultimately I had to actually go and
do it but that was a terrible idea
probably
I call him Channing Tate yum